c'est une expression qu'il faut employer
avec des pincettes ou peut-être même
qu'il faut gagner vous allez donner
votre avis c'est le grand remplacement
cette théorie selon laquelle il aurait
un remplacement des populations
autochtones en europe en france
notamment par des populations d'origine
immigrée voire même que ce remplacement
serait voulu et organisé par les élites
c'est cette théorie que met en avant le
terroriste de la fusillade de
christchurch la semaine dernière en
nouvelle zélande pour justifier son acte
il le compare l'immigration à une
invasion
on a interrogée marine le pen hier sur
france 3 sur sur ce concept
et elle répond clairement je ne connais
pas cette théorie je ne sais pas je ne
connais pas cette théorie théorie du
grand remplacement voulant réfuter vous
il ya des gens moi je n'ai jamais
utilisé ce terme là mais c'est pas le
sujet alors si vous le permettez pour
pour fixer le débat je pense qu'on peut
dire qu'il ya deux questions
derrière ce derrière ce thème la
première question c'est est-ce que ça
correspond à une réalité
ce remplacement alors il ya une partie
de réponse que je trouvais intéressante
parce qu'elle est nouvelle dans le
dernier livre de jérôme fourquet qui
s'appelle l'archipel français dans
lequel il
il a recensé les prénoms arabo-musulman
donner aux enfants nés en france et il
dit ça représentait 2 % des naissances
en 1964 ça représente 18 8 % des
naissances aujourd'hui en fin en 2016
presque une naissance sur cinq donc
c'est pas le grand remplacement parce
que ces minoritaires mais il ya une
progression qui est claire deux de ses
populations
issus de l'immigration arabo musulmane
et puis il ya un deuxième élément
derrière cette théorie c'est l'idée que
tout ça serais voulu qu'il y aura une
forme de complot et selon une autre
enquête menée par la fondation jean
jaurès
en janvier dernier un quart des français
un quart en tout cas des gens interrogés
dans cette enquête crois que
l'immigration est organisée délibérément
par dose élites politiques
intellectuelles et médiatiques pour
aboutir à terme au remplacement de la
population européenne par une population
immigrée voilà introduction un peu
longue mais je trouve que c'est
important de fixer un petit peu les
idées
est-ce qu'il faut employer cette
expression car une volonté de grand
remplacement ou est-ce qu'il faut la
bannir s'étaient créés sont des grands
remplacement elle fait référence à
renaud camus pourquoi il ya une théorie
un théoricien je crois que
beaucoup de gens ici et certainement pas
cette l'horrible type qui a fait cette
immonde attentats en nouvelle zélande
n'ont lu un livre de renaud camus enfin
moi j'ai vu les loges du paraître qui
est un livre magnifique
j'essaie de lire oued à vista c'est trop
compliqué pour moi mais c'est un pur
mais renaud camus n'est pas fasciste
n'est pas un homme qui prône la violence
et et employer ce terme 3000 étaient
employés c'est en fait partir du
principe que renaud camus serait à
l'origine de cette tuerie donc on va
laisser ce sujet de côté ça c'est
absurde c'est ce que prétend d'ailleurs
tous les gens qui se battent qui ceux
qui prônent la liste est ouverte
n'en parlons pas dans ce cadre là dans
ce goût dans le cadre de christchurch
nous n'avons rien à voir avec 13 ch
scratcheur ce n'est pas en france ce
type fait des références qu'il voulait
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'on est
responsable de ce qui s'est passé là
maintenant il ya un autre point qui est
peut-on parler de temps en parler je
vais revenir à ce que vous disiez sur
sur voir ce que l'on voit pendant très
longtemps et jusqu'au bout cannes
fourquet on avait beau avoir déniché
tribalat qui nous informait sur la
démographie des des d'ailleurs il y
avait au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur notamment quelqu'un qui
s'appelle michel aubin qui va sortir un
livre dans très peu de temps
qui veut faisait des rapports à son
ministre et qu'il disait pour chaque
personne qui rentre ça fait quatorze
personnes ou 8,20 en fait entre leur
regroupement familial les enfants la
famille qui vient sa fille kurt 14
personnes de plus on avait des chiffres
qui nous indiquait qu' on avait beaucoup
d'immigration qu' on était dans un pic
d'immigration contrairement à ce que d
hervé le bras ce par exemple prétendait
aujourd'hui on a 18 % des enfants qui
naissent qui ont un nom arabe et
musulman ça montre bien que oui il ya
une grande modification de 2,2 du profit
de la population donc dire est ce qu'on
parle de grand remplacement ben je sais
pas mais on peut quand même déjà
commencé à évoquer cette modification de
composition de la population et à
réfléchir à conséquence est ce qu'on
veut la continuer est ce qu'on veut la
freiner est ce qu'elle est dangereuse
c'est ce qu'elle est compliquée alors
ensuite prétendre que les gens sont
complotistes parce qu'ils voient ce
qu'ils voient quand ils baladent dans
des banlieues parisiennes ou danser ou à
roubaix et c'est parce que il estime qu'
un remplacement
je trouve ça profondément profondément
méprisant dire que les gens n'ont même
plus le droit de tirer des conséquences
de ce qu'il voit et sachant qu'en plus
on était jusqu'à maintenant et pendant
très longtemps dans un
dans un état est dans un pays où ne
pouvait pas évoquer des chiffres sans se
faire traiter de tous les noms et
d'extrême droite east dire parlons de ce
qui se passe sur le plan des populations
évoquons pourquoi ça se passe et
essayant de mettre en place des
politiques une vraie politique de
migration que jusqu'à présent on n'a pas
réussi à mettre en plein air si car une
femme enceinte georges et kuzmanovic
votre point de vue goyer d'abord un mot
sur ce qui s'est passé à christchurch
tout à fait abusant de la part de
quelqu'un qui est l'héritier de colomb
puisque il me semble qu'il est blanc et
qu'ils ont écrasé les populations
locales marguerie un peu comme on fait
les nouveaux américains des populations
indiennes donc je sais pour la boutade
le grand remplacement des jo ce qu'en
fait non c'est une boutade de quoi on
parle
dans ce cas du conte remplacement on a
un problème on n'est pas en allemagne
et si non en france et en allemagne il a
droit du droit du sang n'a pas d'euro du
sang en france même conception de la
nation et de la citoyenneté qui est qui
est d'ordre politique pour revenir se
source sur les chiffres de jérôme
fourquet puisque j'ai eu la malchance
d'être enseignant au lance-pierre en
université en statistiques si vous avez
une population majoritaire vous avez 82%
des noms qui sont français et que vous
avez une population minoritaire ou il ya
18,2 pour sont des noms qui sont à
consonance étrangère
le gap entre ceux qui sont plus français
c'est là rires il ya plus de genre
français que que des gens des minorités
puisque le pourcentage de non français
est plus important que le pourcentage de
noms étrangers même si je dois
simplement à la cour oui la sirène la
cour vraiment mais l'écart en fait sa
croix puisque la population est jeune
elle est plus jeune cette population on
verra et donc mais ça ramène le point
principal c'est la question est ce que
est ce qu on est républicain on n'est
pas républicain et le souci dont
d'ailleurs tout ça parce que vous avez
décrit dans certaines par certains dans
certains quartiers de france où il ya
des concentrations de population et où
il ya des manifestations parfois d'une
religion ou de ou de comportements qui
ne sont pas républicains le problème
n'est pas une question de technique le
problème et de la calanque de république
et le problème c'est d'appliquer le
modèle intégrateur français qui est
celui de l'assimilation républicaine et
c'est absolument ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut mener
et si vous faites ça et que vous appelez
kevin où mohamed
si vous êtes poli pour expects et
l'ordre républicain avec vous travaillez
dans la société mais vous êtes français
et puis on a jamais de problème
merci et c'est d'ailleurs sur les
secours sur la nécessité d assimilation
qui vous salue marie nick quelques
difficultés avec votre avec votre parti
la france a soumis
voilà ce commentaire de monsieur
babineau cette théorie circule dans les
réseaux d'extrême droite
c'est très sérieux pour eux mais
concrètement c'est un énorme fantasmes
anne-sophie le tac votre point de vue
alors bon moi je peux enfin je crois pas
du tout grand remplacement bien sûr
parce que grand emplacement c'est une
théorie complotiste
je suis absolument hostile aux
complotistes j'y suis allergique
littéralement et en plus je trouve que
ça prend même une un aspect
apocalyptique maintenant c'est à dire
que je trouve d'ailleurs au passage je
me permets de faire une petite insiste
pour dire que je suis frappé par la
vision apocalyptique qu'on a des choses
le survivalisme a vendu l'immigration
mais aussi le survivalisme dans d'autres
domaines on a cette vision apocalyptique
même sur le climat jeudi pas du tout que
c'est pas une situation grave mais on
voit des enfants qui disent j'ai peur de
mourir dans trois ans si je fais pas
quelque chose pour le climat bref où on
génère quelque chose de extrêmement
anxiogène alors maintenant donc sur le
grand emplacement
je peux peut-être je voudrais me
concentre et moi sur ce monsieur qui
s'appelle comme ça je me souviens plus
oui c'est ça brenton parentin c'est à
son nom c'est très intéressant ce sont
ce qu'ils sont itinéraire parce qu'en
fait il est venu en france faire un
voyage
c'est une espèce de con tre djihadistes
globalisé disait un spécialiste
suppression blanc un suprémaciste blanc
mais ce qui est rare du terroriste de
nouvelles voilà tout à fait et alors ce
qui est très intéressant c'est qu'il a
beaucoup voyagé il a voyagé en corée du
nord il a été dans beaucoup d'endroits
et il est venu en france et c'est il
prétend que dick concédant venant en
france dans une petite vidéo l'aise
qu'il a été tellement choqué par la
présence de nombreux immigrés que il ay
là il a décidé d'agir musulmans parce
qu'on ne sait pas s'ils sont immigrés ou
donc voilà on se lève est tout à fait
mais alors ça c'est dense pour le coup
dans son dans son fantasme mais alors on
voit bien cette espèce de mouvance
mondialisé qui d'ailleurs rejoint tout à
fait le djihadisme il ya des choses qui
sont différentes et les choses qui sont
communes
ce qui est commun c'est l'idée qu'on
peut pas se métisser pour les
djihadistes et part il n'y a pas de
métissage possible lui parente c'est la
diaspora c'est le métissage biologique
et culturelle mais finalement il ya des
choses qui sont qui sont communes
et puis il ya tout ce monde du jeu vidéo
ce monde aussi de de la fascination pour
l'héritage fasciste et il
et finalement renaud camus rentre en un
peu on sait pas trop comment dans cette
danse est enfin bien sûr il prend la
théorie du remplaçant mais on sait pas
très bien dans quelle mesure ils là il a
vraiment lu mais je pense que en tout
cas il ya une chose qui est certaine
c'est que je pense que face à ce qui est
ce qui est en train de se passer là nos
réponses sont des réponses littéralement
absurde et par exemple ce qu'on a
entendu sur l'antisémitisme avec
l'agression de deux alain finkielkraut
ce qu'on a entendu ce qu on entend même
là sur la semaine du racisme et de
l'antisémitisme
je trouve que ce sont des réponses
absurde parce que des ces gens là qui
sont certes des extrémistes ne ne sont
absolument pas sur ceux sur cette
logique là sur ce registre là par
exemple je voulais juste revenir sur
votre dichotomie distinction de départ
parce que ça me semble très important
c'est le point commun c'est ça qui est
drôle est paradoxal c'est qu'il ya deux
irréfutable it et d'un côté dirait lire
et pull tabilité des faits il ya plus
d'immigration il ya plus de populations
arabo-musulmanes c'est incontestable et
2 pourquoi je critique aussi comme vous
l'argument complotistes qui se cache
derrière cette expression là pourquoi
parce qu'elle est irréfutable c'est ça
le problème du complotisme c'est qu'on
ne peut pas démontrer que ça n'existe
pas et quand c'est indémontrable c'est
irréfutable c'est pour ça que le
complotisme n'a aucune valeur
rationnelle parce que c'est la démarche
exactement inverse de la démarche
rationnelle au lieu de confronter ses
croyances et ses idées aurel
on essaye de distordre le réel pour le
faire rentrer dans son idéologie et
c'est donc pourquoi je critique le
complotisme parce que c'est plus un
symptôme le symptôme d'une pensée
malades
enfin c'est le c'est un symptôme qui se
prend pour un diagnostic c'est ça qui
est exaspérant dans le conte petit snack
fois le grandia semant le grand
emplacement statistiquement n'a aucun
sens non non jamais je serai acheter une
toute petite fille très vite mais juste
une petite chose sur cette histoire des
noirs à bouts musulmans il ya plein de
manières de l'expliquer par exemple
aujourd'hui les populations musulmanes
donne plus de non-musulmans coq
autrefois où elle donnait plus de nos
français y avait une francisation et qui
a quatre cas c'est un manque de
reconnaissance
revendiquant ses entités et pas
seulement 6 d'augmentation de la
population absolument des grand chose à
vous donne des prénoms qui n'ont aucun
sens
en tout cas vous devez vous prouver
qu'on peut parler rationnellement de ce
sujet merci je sais qu'on peut parler de
léa salamé et c'est vraiment très
important je pense que c'est très
important aussi de dire que le coup il
ya on parle de complotisme pour au sujet
des gens qui pensent que la terre est
plate
on parle de complotisme au sujet des
gens qui disent que des le monde est
gouverné par les illuminati
et puis la même façon on parle de
complotisme au niveau 2 du fait qu'il y
ait de plus en plus de deux populations
qui sont issus de l'immigration arabo
musulmane je suis désolé c'est pas le
même sujet puisqu'on a distingué au
parlement avant de dire et aussi du
complot réfléchissons par exemple il ya
quand même des gens des économistes qui
vous disent il ya 30 millions de postes
qui ne sont pas pourvus dans
l'hémisphère nord
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont prêts à
travailler dans l'hémisphère sud va
prendre les 30 millions mamba et on va
les mettre en haut
bon ben il ya aussi un choix qui était
passé pour les récents sur elle mais
pour des raisons économiques
ouais enfin la direction mise mais c'est
ce que dit la rochelle j'ai peut-être
complotistes yves cochet aussi car elles
veulent en temps vous l'attendez donc le
voile à ce sujet consacré à léa salamé
nôtre